happy fourth of july america i'm in a
forest
why am i in a forest well myself and
andy here are working on a bunch of
sweet features about the video game no
man's sky
we're in an alien world all these trees
are a different color probably i don't
know
which is for game spots the next big
game feature which is a thing we do
every month where we highlight a game
that we think is worthy of further
exposure and then do a bunch of sweet
videos giving you extra details on the
game so over e3 we sat down with the
guys from hello games to find out more
about their game and talk about the hype
train that they currently find
themselves riding i always enjoy sitting
down to talk to sean and this time was
no different he enjoys talking about
design the industry the audience and how
all those things inform the games his
team make in fact there was one
discussion that we got into which
touched upon something that i've been
thinking a lot about lately
that all the journalists who ask us how
many levels will there be missions will
every quest i'm interested in making
something different you know i still
enjoy them and stuff but i find games
often really predictable do you think
that like a lot of games show their
cards too early that like
often the the they're spoiled by the
fact that we just know so much about
them
yeah two things
one is
abs absolutely
like games i play them i already know
what's gonna happen i know the type of
game that it is especially in the kind
of aaa area
they have to make it like that they're
making
games to like a blueprint
because it costs so much because the
content costs so much you know i don't
mean to slag off those games i love
those games but a lot of games hide kind
of by the numbers design behind
massive production budgets betting
content you've seen it like all the time
just like minecraft isn't like a big
reference point for us or anything like
that but i do
it has some parts that i just really
admire like minecraft never told you
what the formulas were for crafting
things
and i don't think i ever would have done
that as a designer right
bold move but it's so cool you know it's
just
so nice for a game to just go
figure it out because that's the games
that i grew up with as a kid and i like
that and and people are cleverer than
what
games designers think
so is sean right are games getting so
predictable and are they marketed so
much that by the time they come out any
sense of wonder we might have had around
them is completely gone and if that is
true what are the implications for aaa
games and the video game press at gdc i
attended a fantastic panel by jim
crawford creator of frog fractions a
wonderful trojan horse of a game which
people recommend to each other without
really telling each other the surprise
of what it actually is you should
probably check it out in his panel
entitled preserving a sense of discovery
in the age of spoilers jim talked about
how the immediacy of information created
by the internet has all but destroyed
the sense of wonder we used to have
around games back in the nez era or
earlier back when i was playing
commodore games as a kid we'd know
basically nothing about a game before
playing it save for some details rumors
and screenshots
but it was in that vacuum of confirmable
information that something wonderful
happened when i grew up my only resource
for game information were my friends our
playground conversations were full of
conspiracy theories about hidden levels
easter eggs cheat codes and secret games
in development the source was usually a
magazine maybe somebody's brother or
more often than not just totally made up
but the lack of ability to instantly
google the facts gave these rumors life
back then the media were the gatekeepers
they sprinkled us with new information
screenshots release dates and interviews
morsels of information we'd salivate
over but even then the games were still
mysterious we didn't see gameplay until
the game was in our machines today we
know just about everything about aaa
games by the time they come out launch
trailers tone trailers story trailers
multiplayer details previews features
betas twitch streams and 15 hour long
gameplay clips on youtube and these
games are often so prescribed so
mechanically uninteresting that by the
time the game comes out we basically
know everything about it we know what
we're going to play there are very few
games that surprise us anymore but when
they do they tend to blow up when
minecraft launched people didn't really
know what it was in fact it was often
easier to tell people just to play it
and as we did we learned together about
how that world works how the game works
how to craft items how to enter the
nether
how redstone operated
it's not alone we've seen this before
with dark souls rust plague incorporated
kerbal goat simulator hell the week
after watchdogs was released it was
knocked off the number one slot by the
forest a buggy uncompleted alpha game
which captured the imagination of gamers
all around the world
and what exploded on steam last week a
game about driving cars out of the mud
there's a whole new generation of gamers
the minecraft generation as sean puts it
an audience who craves the new who
chases wonder an audience that just
wants to play exciting and new games
regardless of if they're alpha's beta's
big budget small budget or no budget at
all often times we get locked in a very
old dance publishers are so busy
scrambling for exposure that they often
oversaturate us with information and the
games press are more than willing to
stay in step because it's the only way
they know how to get traffic
but that tune has been coming to an end
for a while it's just not good enough
anymore unimaginative games are shutting
down studios and unimaginative reporting
is shutting down game sites that's why
myself and andy spent an evening at e3
talking to the folks at hello games not
to grab an easy headline placate a pr or
buy ourselves an exclusive trailer but
to talk about a game that has rekindled
a wonder that is so rare in triple a
releases so join us next week on the
next big game no man's sky where we'll
answer plenty of your questions and
leave plenty of new questions
wonderfully unanswered
this week's after bang dance is
dedicated to the memory of ryan davis
now i'm not doing this [__] i shine
bright in the dark like a luminous edge
you're not a failure at all if the shoe
doesn't fit it means the picture was
bigger than you didn't expect
you